we didn't really see oil come off any on
the Iran deal but the estimate is
perhaps anywhere between five and ten
dollars a barrel if we do see a lot of
oil come on what does that wind up
meeting here at home well you know
markets all markets are forward-looking
including oil markets now we can't
extract what's been going on with
concerns over Greece and China and
specifically how Iran is affecting oil
prices but I imagine some of the decline
we've seen in oil prices was in reaction
to anticipation or the anticipation of a
deal from Iran with Iran being announced
so people saw this coming in other words
I think they saw it coming it's been
well televised and so investors as you
know love to bet and they would have
been embedding on what it would mean for
oil if there was more supply coming
online from Iran so oil prices have
declined what it means for consumers is
it's always a good thing right stable
and low oil prices lead to stable and
low gasoline prices it means you don't
pay as much when you go to gas up at the
pump that's always good news at the very
least it makes consumers feel better
what's the lag time for that will the
lag time between oil prices and gasoline
retail prices is about two weeks oh so
pretty soon you start seeing it
immediately goat flows through into
wholesale gasoline prices and then with
about in about two weeks we see it flow
through into lower gasoline prices at
the pump retail prices what you and I
pay what Joe would pay if he drives a
car but he's been living in Manhattan a
long time yeah so all right let's shift
to the US econ we got two pieces of bad
economic data this morning I mentioned
them earlier we got that and if I be
small business optimism survey surprised
drop from last month that wasn't good
news and then the other thing and
probably much many more people pay
attention to it it goes into people's
GDP calculations a really weak retail
sales number we had hoped to see this
media recovery from the early start of
the year not only was this a big missed
last month was revised down so what's
going on with the US economy well I
think for the business surveys and we
have our own business conditions survey
as well which bobbled lately with the
concerns over what's been going on in
Greece and with volatility and markets
from China just the uncertainty was
higher in the economy and you'll see
that feed through into sentiment in the
surveys so I don't want to put too much
in the NFIB survey showing some signs of
weakness there let's get into July let's
get with into an area where the dust has
settled now on the retail sales number
we had a big jump in May retail sales
data tend to mean revert that means that
if it was a big jump in one month we
tend to get a decline in the next month
I am heartened that the decline it was
as small as it was given such a large
increase in May what what ultimately
economists want to see is a July report
that we would consider a clean report
because we don't know how much may sales
were boosted by an earlier than usual
Memorial Day holiday so may and june the
wash and all the tension we should all
be watching that july sales report for
the definitive focus on the july report
but i tell you what i am heartened by
the fact that the payback was less than
it could have been in june in the june
retail sales data so we have real
consumer spending tracking
two-point-nine percent growth in the
second quarter compared to 2.1 percent
growth in the first quarter that is a
higher rate of spending and anything
near three percent like that means that
your entire economy is going to grow
somewhere near three percent something
that stood out to me though in the
retail sales number was that restaurant
and bar spending was actually down and I
know that Joe and I talked about this a
lot is sort of you're here to go there
first to spend your extra money for
spending their you're definitely going
to buy something from Amazon so what was
your take on that specific read so I
tell you what out of the entire retail
sales report that is probably the most
important line item and so you notice
that this is a category that raced along
when gasoline prices started dropping
last year and throughout the entire
winter months never once did we stop
drinking or eating out when that happens
I say the kids are all right you know
because that's the first thing we cut
back on it's the first thing we do when
we feel good as we go out to eat so I am
concerned that we did have a tick down
in the in the June retail sales data
report for that line item but that was
the first bobble in a very long string
of the strong months for that category
so it does bear watching because the
first place households will put back if
they're feeling angst about their
finances is that category spending but
you look at the labor market you look at
other things going on the domestic US
economy and there's nothing that I can
point my fingers to and say AHA
households should be worried